I saw you had like the world's largest
scooter I won the world's record with
the Guinness World Book records but then
they almost sued me too why would they
see you this dude I found him on
Craigslist he said he was an official
and as it turns out when we were filming
it the dude literally had no affiliation
he had the whole outfit and everything
how much does something like that cost
you it was upwards of half a million for
that scooter yeah those are Harley
Davidson motorcycle wheels the whole
thing is made out of nuclear grade
titaniums do you still have the scooter
of course I have a half a mill yeah I'd
like to think I still have it I think I
could sell it for a lot my idea was I
was gonna sell it and then build one
that was one entire and then break the
record again but I felt bad about so I
decided against it